[Music]
i had a lot of fears about things and
about dying and i think everyone has
that but i
i'm over that now i mean i've confronted
the worst thing
that can happen
[Music]
i'm a pretty positive person generally
although breast cancer is a scary thing
to go through i felt that in in my
deepest
core and in my soul i knew that i would
get through it
[Music]
once you're so close to the possibility
of dying
everything gets put in the right
perspective
and i feel grateful every day
that i'm here
[Music]
olivia was first diagnosed with breast
cancer in 1992 she underwent chemo and
radiation and lived cancer free for a
while but the disease would return more
than two decades later this time in her
lower back choosing a more holistic
approach she treated the effects of
cancer with medical marijuana i'm very
very lucky that i have a wonderful
husband who grows medicinal cannabis for
me that's been helping me with pain in
fact i don't even know if i have pain
because i take it on a regular basis and
i feel very good and i think it's doing
much more for me than just for pain
[Music]
one of olivia's lasting legacies is
greece she was actually 29 years old and
one of the world's most popular singers
with nine number one singles before
being cast as high school senior sandy
who was hopelessly devoted to john
travolta's danny john had to convince
the studio to cast olivia
[Music]
they had brought up linda ronstadt
they'd brought up marie osmond
and i said
they're wonderful i said but every every
guy in the world wants olivia and john
as
their
but after that olivia told us she almost
turned the part down i wanted to do a
screen test to see if i thought i could
do it i was worried about two things one
that i could pull off the roll and two
that i'd pull off 18 or 17 because i was
29
and john was a few years younger than me
so i said no
tell me about it
for the movie's final scene where sandy
undergoes a transformation went out on
the set
and nobody knew who i was and i was
getting all these
looks and whistles and i've seen what
have i been doing wrong all these months
and it was really uh
very fun it was really fun that i could
pull it off and those skin tight pants i
was stitched into them because the zip
or the thing on the side was broken it
was they were really old i think they
were actually from the 50s so even in
the 70s they were old needless to say i
didn't drink or eat much
on those days when we were filming
[Music]
those pants were later auctioned off in
2019 to benefit olivia's cancer center
in australia the billionaire founder of
spanx bought them for more than 160
thousand dollars
[Music]
of course olivia's career extends far
beyond greece she started as a singer
and won four grammy awards singing just
kind of
happened for me i used to do it for fun
and somebody heard me singing in a
coffee lounge i went into a talent
contest and won it and it kind of
you know spiraled from there in 1981 she
recorded her most controversial song
which wasn't played on some radio and tv
stations for being too sexual
you were banned for this song and this
song is like a lullaby compared to what
we hear on the radio today it's nothing
the things that are out there now the
things they talk about and say like
freak me out so yeah
it is like a lullaby
olivia leaves behind her husband john
and daughter chloe who did a duet dance
single with her mom
[Music]
olivia stood by her only child when they
came to e.t in 2007 to reveal chloe had
overcome a battle with anorexia i think
she's amazing
and the fact that she wanted to come out
and talk about it rather than be talked
about and say that you know i've gone
through this and it's a difficult thing
to admit and and i just um have a lot of
admiration for her only since i've
gotten older i've been able to really
stand back and i used to be like oh
she's just mom but now i look at her and
what she's gone through
what an incredible human being she is
her
how genuine she is my mom like blows me
away i love you
i'm grateful for every day and the other
choice is not so great so i think to
appreciate
moments because those moments are
what make life special and
i feel very lucky
[Music]
you